c'est l'anniversaire d'Alexandre
guerrier
[Applaudissements]
bon anniversaire mon chéri s'il vous
plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri est-ce que il y a un cadeau
que je pourrais te faire qui te ferait
plaisir à part fermer ma gueule
non mais le nombre de fois que tu
utilises mon téléphone j'aimerais bien
avoir
[Applaudissements]
et vous avez raison qui est ce ville
personnage qui travaille au côté de Baba
et bien cette personne c'est Alexandre
guerrier
qui est là avec moi mes côtés depuis des
années maintenant il est arrivé il avait
six ans
et là maintenant il demande un téléphone
GSM
et mobile
tu vas un téléphone
[Applaudissements]
je propose des Pouilles non je vous
explique faut faire le jeu c'est pas
c'est pas un cadeau d'anniversaire c'est
un cadeau d'adieu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que tu peux expliquer au
téléspectateurs ce que tu fais quand
même au sein de l'émission
des chroniqueurs à les emmener jusqu'au
plateau et après il y a les intervenants
aussi aller leur expliquer
[Applaudissements]
il y a toute une équipe
j'adore
et bien je vais jouer pour Marion
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ah oui tu as raison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
je vais jouer demande une bagnole les
séries ça va être très simple les séries
ça va être très simple
on va jouer Alexandre guerrier puisque
c'est son anniversaire contre moi si
Alexandre guerriergane il gagne son
téléphone ok si je gagne c'est toutes
les équipes qui rapportent avec un
téléphone
[Applaudissements]
c'est méchant mais on aime Alexandre je
pense qu'à toi
c'est peut-être
tout le monde a le détester
je mets pour JB tout ça vous inquiétez
pas est-ce que tu veux commencer en
premier alors excuse-moi tu te prends
pour qui
il a pris une taille comme ça
vous devriez faire un chifoumi parce que
je suis le patron c'est toi qui commence
qu'à toi force qu'à toi elle est belle
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais dire aux équipes les règles
j'ai l'impression qu'Alexandre guerrier
ne vous aime pas
il vous méprise Amaury pense que je vais
gagner mais c'est en combien d'essence
en un seul coup
je suis quand même d'autres choses à
[__] dans l'émission
est-ce que si chaque anniversaire
une demi-heure d'émission on est là en
juillet fais attention
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la dernière fois le dernier smartphone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà et voilà Cyril vous pouvez pas
laisser Alexandra anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
vous gagnez pour offrir 20 iPhone faites
la fête il y en avait qu'un seul à
offrir normalement vous êtes à l'école
et vous pourrez lui prêter
[Applaudissements]